oh yeah right at seven o'clock they're
cheering for you around me
[Laughter]
all right folks looks like a lot of
people are coming in
um hopefully you get to hear a lot of
the cheering it's a pretty cool
experience of new york and hear the
cheering at this hour
we'll give everyone a chance to start up
piling into the room i know there's a
bunch of people coming
so welcome to everyone who's already
gotten in and we'll just sit tight for a
few moments
while everyone else clicks in then we'll
start off our announcements then go to
our speaker
give a few minutes a few moments of dead
air which everyone always enjoys when
they're first getting to a zoo meeting
when everyone's sound are you on mute
what's going on
all right you see actually we have a few
call in people that's pretty great
you'll be able to hear it at least
let me see ken is here joyce dusty
i see andre there's a lot of people here
i thought i'm not gonna name everybody
who's trying to pick out names i
recognize from
the meetup i'm sure i'm gonna miss a lot
of you so sorry people i'm not gonna
call your name just too many for me to
call out
okay just another minute and then
we'll get started
yeah i could see already uh
bubba included that we have people
coming to us from
other places outside new york which is
you know while we're unfortunate that
we're all um
quarantine not able to join in person it
is nice that we're able to get people
from
all over the world now i know we had
some folks in
i believe michigan actually uh message
us we have people in dc area
we have um people come from the west
coast some people in europe it's late
for them
you know some people from europe coming
and as always
we always do our best to make our
content available to everybody
afterwards so we'll see if we'll try to
get this online
and have everyone access to us i know
it's late hours in some parts of the
country or some parts of the world i
should say
people are coming in from so thank you
everyone for coming
so i'll get started slowly since i know
some people are still filtering in
people trailing
it's not like when we're in person you
can see the room being full people can
come at any minute here
so first things first as we always do at
the meetup we have to do a little bit
differently this time
but people who are regular attendees now
i like to ask who is hiring what jobs
are available
now of course we can't do that we can't
have people stand up and announce that
here because that'd be chaos so
if anyone wants to announce a job if you
go to our slack team
there is a job postings channel and if
you don't know about our slack team
actually if a mod if you can include in
the chat a link to the sign
up link on nyhakar.org but if you don't
know about it
the meetup has a website nyhackr.org
that's hack the letter r
and whitehackr.org on there you'll find
information about upcoming events you
will find
the link to the slack team and you'll
also find presentations
we have about 10 years of presentations
and six years of videos
of the meetups so there's a topic you
want to learn you go to nyhacar.org go
to presentations
and then you search for a topic or a
search for a speaker
so there's lots of different ways to be
able to see that information
so that's all the roundabout way of
saying that if you want to talk about a
job you're trying to hire
put it in the job postings channel of
that slack team and that way we can
get you get you some people who want a
job it's a great opportunity for people
who need a job people want to hire
and everyone comes together so speaking
of
that slack team we created a channel
called may 14
dash meetup so if you want to
participate chat with each other
that's a great place to do it the may 14
dash meetup
and if you have questions since we can't
ask questions afterwards like we
normally do in person
go to that channel may 14 meet up ask
your question in there
then at the end of the end of the talk i
will ask the question to rami
and then he will give you the answer
you're looking for so if everyone could
go to the may 14th meetup channel and
ask your questions
if you can't get onto the slack for
whatever reason
you can ask it in the chat window here
on zoom
that's a little harder to check a little
harder to read so if you can do the
slack please do it
but the zoom channel will be sufficient
given the theme of our talk tonight's
about covet 19 again
um we have a coven 19 channel and
actually it's funny so last month we had
noam here talking about analysis of
covet 19.
this month we have rami talking about
the data for covent 19.
we probably should have done that
backwards but this is the way things
worked out so now you've got to get your
data and you can go apply everything
noem taught you last month
so that's the coven 19 channel in fact i
know i've posted some of romi's
resources about a month ago
i posted it there so feel free to jump
in there and chat about today's meetup
chat about cover 19
and join in we have over 11 000 talented
data scientists many of you are in
bioinformatics
and even epidemiology go in there and
help each other let's help crack this
mystery a little bit if we can
um next month we are actually hopefully
if these things work out inspired by
noam we are going to have
gavin simpson come talk to us all the
way from azeem alberta canada i believe
talk to us about gams uh gams appear to
be this magical
machine learning technique or
statistical learning whatever you want
to call it
and one of the most popular talks ever
given was noam's talk about
gams so now we have gavin ross who's
sorry gavin simpson
who has promised to one-up noam's talk i
just gave him that challenge we'll see
if he can do it
speaking of other activities and other
events
eram the european r user meeting i
believe i got the acronym right eram
was supposed to have taken place like
yesterday
in mulan for obvious reasons it's not
taking place
in milan anymore and it's going to go
virtual next
month it's uh june second week of june i
believe i don't have the exact dates on
me
but the second week of june eram will be
taking place is essentially
whenever user is in america which it was
supposed to be this year
eram takes place in milan so it's going
to be coming up in june
uh we'll post a link in the slack and in
the group chat
for a link to e-ram it's a really cool
conference if you want to attend
virtually you can
and cool conferences new york
r a lot of you've been asking the
original dates were
tomorrow or last week this past friday
and this past thursday friday and
saturday
they were rescheduled to june
unfortunately june doesn't seem like
it's going to be happening in new york
so we are looking at ways to make the
new york r conference virtual
in august stay tuned we have a lot more
information we
just this morning my team was testing
out some of the platforms we have we're
finding some really cool platforms
going to make this as much fun and
accessible as possible no it's not going
to have as much food as we normally do
because you know we are distant from you
we are going to try to make it as fun as
possible and as true to our spirit as
possible
many of you have been to the conference
many of you have spoken at the
conference or volunteered
you know how you try to make it such a
great fun welcoming environment full of
just liveliness we're doing our best to
recreate the constraints we have so
august time frame the new york r
conference
check it out soon uh the website hasn't
been updated yet you're some of the
first people we're telling about the
august timeline
uh so please uh stay tuned for that
uh it's gonna i'm really looking forward
to it i'm satisfied in person but i'm
excited that we're at least going to
bring some of the wonderful content to
you
in addition to the conference we have a
series of workshops that are all going
virtual
a few weeks ago we had the stand
workshop uh going forward we have a few
others
it turns out for workshops virtual works
pretty nicely uh so we're gonna put a
few more of those
the topics are still open
for people to say what they want we have
a few ideas so let us know if there's a
topic you want to learn let us know
in the past we have had um time series
we've done machine learning
we have done um gis we've done all sorts
of things
to to bring to you so if you have a
topic you want to do
just let us know
dcr which is our dc version of new york
car is still
scheduled for november we're going to
see how that plays out if the country
reopens we'll do it in november
if the country hasn't reopened yet over
that's going to go virtual as well
and another thing people uh are aware of
is that we usually do our pizza poll and
so as you can't do in person but i went
and got pizza once again from a
different place
i'll continue to go in a different place
each month you can see it's been here
for a little bit i've been holding a
slice for a little bit
we have good cheese lock decent charring
it's nice thinness
good tip sack because it's a nice thin
slice of pizza
so i hope everyone else has had a chance
to get their slice of pizza
and bring it to the meetup it's byop uh
whoever
everyone is enjoying their pizza here
and that's such a big component of our
meetup so i'm continuing to keep the
tradition alive
virtually well for real it's really
going to go to my mouth
and unfortunately we can't go to the bar
afterwards like we like doing so often
so i hope everyone could join us on
slack
chat in there and maybe have a virtual
beer or a virtual non-alcoholic beverage
as you choose
so with all that i am very excited to
bring not our first virtual speaker
actually we actually had someone from
australia speak to us one time years ago
through a video chat back before i want
to say this is 2010.
we had a speaker couldn't come to new
york so we did a video chat it's just
one part of the meetup
this is going to be our fir and gnome
spoke virtually last month but he's in
brooklyn
this is going to be our first of the
quarantine far away speaker
i'm very happy coming from california
rami to talk to us more
about covet 19. so everyone please i
guess at home
a virtual round of applause for romney
thank you very much
thank you it's my first time
doing a virtual meetup that i'm
presenting so i hope it won't be
too awkward
so just today i'm going to speak about
the kobit 19r project which is focused
as jared mentioned about data
this project is a joint effort with the
amanda
dubai which is also a member of this
meetup and with the charity brians
so with that i will jump to
the presentation and stop to present
okay
so um the agenda for today meet up is uh
first i will introduce the concept of
having our data package
then we will jump to the copy 19r
project
and at the end i will show a little bit
how to work with this
uh new concept of working with the
data that is not really live on the
package and
at the end we will have a q a
so one thing i want to start it is what
i'm not
so i'm a not any expert in the
field i'm not expert in a epidural
epidemiologist
or biostatistician and by far i'm not
expert in
disease uh just to set expectations
we're not going to talk on models
uh when i started to work on on the kobe
19
this is something i realized in the
first day that
it's better to leave the modeling part
of the people that actually
expert in this field
and what i am so i'm a data scientist i
love r
i mainly focused on time series and
[Music]
statistical analysis um i'm author of a
book name and hands-on time series
analysis
without which is focus on the
forecasting without
and also auto offers several hour
packages
um that was the one that i have a
hexagon but there are more the
the the one on top is the i guess my
first package that i
released the current ts studio which
focusing on the
tools for time series analysis and other
us grid and us
you can read our example data packages
example for
a time series with the multi
seasonality and the one on the
corner the right top and bottom corner
the corner wires which is
how this project started
i'm sorry to interrupt you but someone
just actually pointed out we're seeing
your speaker slides or presenter notes
we're not seeing the actual oh they in
presentation
oops
oh let me
all right
since we lost the effects i will repeat
it
can you see my screen now
yep perfect thank you okay
sorry about it uh technology challenges
so just uh um for those who
not familiar with the concept of our
data package
so there are i guess i categorize into
two groups of
packages the first one is probably the
most popular
is a package that data in package that
help to communicate
the package functionality so if you
think about it one of the
most common one is the diamond data set
from the digiplot
package uh in my package studio i
i started to gather many packages to
explain some of the functionality of the
package
the second type of packages are the
one that just focused on some provide
some example
or provide accessibility to
data so first and foremost is the data
package that
provide all the uh built-in data sets in
now
and for example those uk create and use
crypto
i created them to provide example for
multi
seasonality time series data and the
other
type of defendant
last is the type of packages is the
one that provides data for analysis
uh or historical events
so there are i guess in the epidermis
in the biostatistic there are a lot of
examples of
this type of data sets and uh
the idea is that you will be able to
load the data smoothly to r without
the need to make any adjustment as
opposed when you're
loading data from csv then you need to
reformat the data
in our package the data it's already
ready to use
and technically it's very simple to
create a data package once you create
the structure of the
the package the skeleton and you have
the data
they use this package as a simple way to
save the data it's put it in the
structure of the data it's available on
the namespace
and once once you load the the package
you can load the data
and start to use it
and there are a few ways those are just
an
example of for those packages how you
create this
package or the source or the workflow
uh typically it should have a data
source it could be
api a gita repository or some
flat files and then you should have some
scripting files to
pull the data and update the data
reformat it
and reformat or create
make it available i typically use either
r
or a bus script when it's a more
intensive and then there are some
utilities
tools such as they use this package and
they
test that package and i forgot also to
put you the dev tools that
enable you to save the data and make
sure that the data is uh
in a good shape and the last part
and it is something i learned recently
is the
automation tools uh that you want to
add to your package is generally a good
tool to have in a packet but especially
when you have a
package that you want to update it and
run a
chrome jobs or to run unit test
you want to use some tools for example
in this case this is the logo of the
github action which is a great tool
so what is different between the kovid
19 data package and start
standout out packages so this is on the
screenshot that i took from a a repo
that many
created for with all the resources of
the
kobe 19 data in r
and this is a short list of the packages
that are available for the
copy 19. the main difference from
normal and startup data package to copy
19 data packet is that this is a
on on ongoing event and i think this is
the first time that
while event is happening people start to
do comment and create the package
the second part and something i learned
in the art way there is uncertainty the
data is keep changing when i started to
create the coronavirus package the first
month was painful
when the data structure
changes change on a daily basis and i
had to
adopt the the code and
reformat it almost every day
then there are data errors that
appear because not always you know you
can be sure that the
source of the data reliable the last is
that the data
need to get updated on a daily basis so
if you compare
this to the iris data set the results
that is the final uh
it will stay there forever and you don't
really care about the time or if you
take the air passenger data set that
it's a good academic example to learn
time series
um they're there and they'll
they're done but the copy 19 is ongoing
event and you need to
find a way to keep the data
update on a daily basis
and this is just example for my the
amount of effort that require
this is my github commit in the last
year
and you can see that since i started to
work on the
kovi 19 data sets it's become
very chaotic and intensive
so jumping to the kovid 19 hour project
uh i thought to give a time timeline and
explain how
it started and the basic ways to when i
started to
uh think how it all started i went to
twitter to
pull the events and i actually thought
it may be
useful to pull the tweets themselves so
on a
february 8th i realized that there is
something
going on with the the this thing is
called coronavirus
and it's become something interesting
and i because i have a passion to
data i decided to try to pull it and
create a package uh it took me like a
a day to find the data on john hopkins
repo
and four days after i had the package
ready
available on my repo
and two weeks after it was already in
crane
then in mount start all the issues a lot
of issues with the data
some of the fields change
the data not always refresh there were
some errors and
i think most of march i spend on
fixing arrows and updating the
structure of the data pool and more
issues with the
[Music]
expanding some of those low to users uh
which was kind of like challenging
and then there will start to come some
pull requests
and there were two really interesting
pull requests one from
jared and the other one from amanda
and jared was
mainly focused on the joseph
special visualization
and the structure of the data and amanda
uh
provided uh l package copy 19
uh us and we try to incorporate with the
co-owner virus and then we start to
realize that
we don't have a common language and
there is no like a standout and merging
all of those three will be
challenging and then we started to talk
about how can we make a uniform format
so that's how the project start and the
goal the main goal of the stor
the project is to make the data
the flow of the data easier and
accessible
and last friday we actually launch it
and
it's now available on the github repo
so the one thing that i probably uh want
to take
hope that people will take from this
meetup is about the structure of the
data
the goal is to make the data as tidy and
uniform
as possible so the project is hosting
multiple data sets from
different countries and they all use the
same format
so all have the same columns
which is the should make sense because
all
any data that's coming now for the kobit
19
is based on location and we had
the a location code and location type
in order to be able to merge the data
with the
visualization tools like this type of
visualization and the idea
is to create data that is ready to use
that user
will be easy to the user to get access
to data
and to develop a contributors community
so we created this document and and our
goal that other people will join us to
the effort to pull
to create data packages for
cov19 and
[Music]
our main goal was to set a low bar
to create a package by providing as much
as possible documentation
and tools so one thing to point out that
we
build uh this book down with instruction
how to build your own
uh data what should be the
unit test that you need to have what
should be the standout
data format or
how to submit it to cran
and we have on our github repository
we have an example of a template for a
kobe 19 package about what should be the
structure
and it's straightforward to
clone it and start your own project
so so far um we have
about 11 ish packages
in the uh project the first two the
convert19r
and the copied our data are
centralized packages that enable you to
the way i think i want people to think
about is the api
that enables people to pull any of the
packages that we are hosting on this
project without the need to install the
package
and i will show it in a second in a
short demo
and then there are specific data
packages like the copy 19 new york
ny times which is the new york times
data sets the kobit knight in france
which is cases in
france canada swiss
italy and this is a new package are just
had yesterday about
data that came from what april releases
recently with the mobility data
one thing that i want to
go well is something that
most of our users probably don't aware
or
don't think it is important but
i found it the art way that this is very
important not only for
a data package but generally when you're
developing package you want to have
to use the continuous integration tools
i found that the github action is is
amazing tool to
create a unit test to structure unit
tests and also
to create conjob so now all the
packages on this project are running
with a
cronjob that enable the data to be
refreshed on a daily base
and ensure that whenever you are
loading you can update the data with the
most recent data
so for example when you submit the cran
you typically don't submit on a daily
basis you submit once in a month or two
but you still want to get the use of the
most recent data and this is
kind of solve this issue
and another thing that um it's important
to emphasize that it's
still work in progress we
started to work on it about two months
ago
and during these two months we kind of
like it took us time to
understand what is the structure that we
want to have or where we want to
what is the final goal
i think that most of it is there and now
it's just
building more tools and functionality
and with that i just go to an example
so first this is the
gita proposed though it will well
have all the packages or in the project
um the main thing to point out is the
documentation
uh which i mentioned before that you
have a
detailed instruction with stillwater but
most of it is there
how to build a kobe 19
a package and the
second part is the covidao package which
i will show in a minute but it just
allowed you to
get all the available data set that
in this project and load it
enough in the most recent data from this
repository
so this is a small example i will just
create the font
so i'm using here the kovid 19
new york times package
so the first thing that you want to do
is install the package
and then you you will see that in this
package there are
two data sets one is the state level
and the other one is the county level
and those are static data sets and they
update
to the last submission
but so when you pull it and you can see
that the
debt of the data the last date is the
estimation date
the structure is following the same
structure as i mentioned before you have
a
date date of the observation you have
the
location which is in this case the
location type is a
a county state location code
which is using fibs which is a standard
for a
a just official
visualization of a county in the u.s
and the type of data so it could because
we're using a long format could be
multiple
types so in this case you have the total
case the total number of
depth recovery and so on
and the last column to value the the
value
that corresponding to the details in
this row
now once the data was uh the packet was
loaded
you can actually get the most recent
data by using the refresh kovit 19
new york times counties what this
function is does
is pulling the data from the kovidar
package
which is refreshing automatically on a
daily base and it's returned the most
recent
data and you can see here this is update
to
yesterday the most with the data up to
yesterday
and then um from here to start a summary
statistic or any
analysis it's straightforward because
the data is already organized
it's clean reformatted and
it's simple so for example if you want
to
get the top 20 counties in the u.s with
the high schools
it's straightforward with the flyer to
filter to the most recent
date in the data pull the
a case total and sort it by
value so
then you can get this table you can also
do another manipulation
but it's straightforward once the data
is ready to use
the other thing is as i mentioned before
[Music]
we have the component that allow you to
easily
uh plot create a
geosufficient visualization uh
one of the things that there are many
types of
a geodata
and this is the reason that we added
those
two columns that for value what is the
type of
a code data that we are
used in this package and in this example
it's the
fifth but in some other cases it it
could come with from the
our natural earth package or different
packages and
once you know it's easy to melt the geo
geometric
data with the with the data itself and
visualize it
so in this case i'm using floatly i'm
loading the
um the field a
county level data and
[Music]
creating the projection and just plot
the data
um and here it's
straightforward there are other cases
that we
actually i can go and show it
so this package is still not fully uh
aligned with the with the structure of
the data
but it will be in the future but this is
example of a
of the geospherical and a visualization
here in this case this is the copyright
in intelli
italy data there are three data sets
available here one is the region level
the province level and the national
level and for the region and the
performance level
[Music]
i'm using the
the geometric code that's available in
the data which i'm merging it with the
geo geometric code that's available on
the our natural
health package so it's very stressful to
load the geometric data from the
unnatural health package create a map
object
and then take this object and merge it
with the
data itself and
from there it's straightforward to
create the
plot the corresponding cloud
so this is basically the
kobe 19 project
i just want to mention again the older
contributor to the packages which is
amanda
dubin uh jarrett ryan's
and morgan a ubas clan
and myself and the last thing is that
we hope that others will join us uh for
this project in order to
help to get more data into all
and to make it accessible to other users
so with that if there is any question i
will be happy to
answer
all right so first thank you very much
for the lovely the lovely wonderful
lovely fantastic whatever adjective you
want to use talk
um thank you so i hope everyone's giving
you a little virtual applause
uh right now uh so
of course it's difficult to um
do questions when we're remote like this
so i'm going to encourage everyone to
put them either in the q a or into the
group chat or into slack we have a few
already
so the first one is um
how do you is there any way to
collaborate with a new data set like how
does someone have a data set get them
into this project yeah so
we actually um i think we have some
other issue that we
we put
with the list of data sets we hope that
someone will
go and help us to
to pull them
let me find it
i think it's somewhere here
yeah so this is a list of resources that
we think that this potential to
incorporate in this project if someone
want to
someone find found a nice data set
that as all the components that we are
looking to have in this
uh type of data meaning that it's a time
series
with a geographic
component so it's straightforward
do you need to have first thing that you
need to have is
a file that pulls the data
from this source so if it's a gita
people you need to have a script that go
to the gita people pull the necessary
data
reformat it and make it ready to use
and then the other thing you need to
follow the format of the package
so there is here the component of how to
build a new package
uh what are the components that you need
to have
in terms of tools that you can use
the function that you need to have in
order to
va compliance with the coffeedow package
and so on so it i found it a very
straightforward and simple process but
again if
someone want every data any needed to
build the package we are more than happy
to help with this
let's answer this question um
i think so and i'll wait for anonymous
attendee if they have chat back in the q
a we'll find out more
um and just a note about that from the
2018 new york r conference actually
noem who i've mentioned a few times
already gave a talk about
data packages in r so that might be a
fun talk for anyone to go
look at it's under our stats that our
stats that ai
the 2018 videos and look for uh data
package that's what you can search for
and has a whole talk about how to create
a data package that maybe you want to
have people watch that before they do a
pr
and speaking of new data someone asked a
question
uh tom asked the question has there been
consideration
i guess from the core covet 19 team
there has been consideration about
adding the google and apple mobility
data that's been looked at some related
to coven 19.
so i know that jarrod start to work on
it and i think it's uh
already there is a template over
somewhere
so it's still an early step
but the idea is to add it to this
package to this
uh project great so coveted 19 mobility
and who's repo is that in
this is so this is uh this is another
project
one of the ripples and then charity is
the one that
actually maintained it and i think it's
like
literally two days ago so good timing
tom
you guys so great time to ask that
question
uh we have a question from
i believe uh from who is this from
from uh uh john john peter sabini
he is asking about are there fine grain
data on the age of patients who died
and the patients who got coveted i guess
you know so where do we get information
about
i guess ages and already how granular
does it get and is there any age
information
so actually i i try to make for this
meetup
a package for new york data that i found
that to provide this information
uh unfortunately i didn't have time and
also the feedback that i received from
the other
members of the team that it might not
view
follow the format but i will share this
link
so this is official data from
[Music]
i think this is oh not this one sorry
there is a
office of health of new york city that
published some
data and actually they provide a
statistic about the age
let me pull it
yeah so this is um new york city called
virus data it's provided by the
department of health
new york city and there is some
actually some nice data that is not
available in other resources
such as the distribution of males and
females there is age
available here
by group and
other so the number of tests
by zip code and so on so it's a very i i
looked at it and fought like this is
really super interesting to do some
descriptive analysis to visualize it
uh if someone wants to take it as a
project
we'll be happy to have it in our project
to bring this data
that's a call to everyone here to jump
right in there and add to it
and that actually goes to tom's question
is help needed
i think the answer probably yes right
yes we
we are working very hard in the last two
months
[Music]
and we will be happy that so the idea is
to create a
community i i would like to think about
it
as the kind of like the entire diverse
of the corona data
um that like the main idea is that to
create community that
instead of each one develop its own
package using a different structure
that we all use the same structure then
it will be
easier to develop a supporting tool so
think about it like
if you use devil the focus package when
you
created uh a focused object
you're going to the base r and you can
plot it with the bezel
because bestseller know how to
communicate so i think that's what we
are trying to do
uh to build a communication channel
about the data
and make sure that we utilize our
resource
better
sorry um so basically i like that theme
the tidy verse analogy
uh saying trying to make it all you know
standardized
and i also like the uh the open source
mentality if you can help definitely
help
i will say however about forecasts
though i switched to fable and use
autoplot to get gg pots out of there
i i i know the favorite is painful
so far i'm trying to get used to it i
realized i need to move to fable but
still i'm kind of like
oh the focus was much more nicer but
it's a different talk yeah yeah
i think there is like all uh part in the
documentation
about how to submit a
a pull request and
uh i'll submit issue and all things it
should be somewhere here
uh i can share it later on but uh
it is straightforward like the process
to
what i'm trying to say is like that it
is straightforward to create a package
if someone
wants to start to build a package i
think it's a good opportunity to learn
how to
build a package because it's not as
complicated the only thing that you need
to build is a function
they take the data from the source and
clean it
this is the only requirement and
if someone want to get practice on
building package
go ahead join us i do like that
i do like that mentality one function
that makes it easy and you're welcoming
uh people to come join you
um and speaking of a time series before
i get to the next question
uh at the meet up we have had i guess
both sides of the time series divide
we've had rob hyman arrow and his team
talk about sybil and
their version of time series and we've
had jeffrey ryan talk about xts
and his version of time series one's
tidy ones make more base r
uh so that's all available in the um on
the meet up
another question actually gets back to a
little bit what you said about the new
york times data
uh there's a question and i don't know
how this fellow this person's name
anymore
but saying have you examined the
difference between the new york the new
york state deaf data the new york times
deaf data
and the department of health mental
hygiene data and they eventually catch
up each other because they're saying the
department of health and mental hygiene
is based on death certificates and it's
more conservative
so have you seen those discrepancies i'm
not sure there's something even bothered
analyzing but have you seen any
discrepancies and
when they eventually catch up to each
other and reconcile
no i did not i was mainly focusing on
the john hopkins
data so my my first package was
using john hopkins and john hopkins are
using different resources
uh the like they're collecting worldwide
and what i saw that sometimes you get
the negative
values and it's the reason for those
discrepancies coming from uh that
each company might uh
count differently in those cases or
there were some errors that they fix it
so i'm sure because we are still i would
consider ourself in an early stage of
this
event and
one of the things that i learned that i
hope that all those organizations are
doing a better job than the way they are
handling the data
because the way most of the
organization if you think about the
european f organization they don't have
api they provide excel files
uh the world organization also they
provide pdfs so people
start to script pdf and i think today
should be a better way to maintain
data by those organizations and i think
this is one of the takeaway form
from the data science perspective
yeah i understand that i remember i did
a project for
the um of the columbia school of health
over 10 years ago about the hurricane
katrina deaths he had the official death
tolls from a death certificate
then he had self-reported death tolls
and there's a lot of discrepancies and a
lot of work went into trying to
reconcile the two of them because
someone has a heart attack during a
hurricane is that
death from the hurricane is that
different type of death that goes into
it
yeah and definitely the there is uh
discrepancy and there's a question about
availability of the data in some cases
that you
coming from some countries that are
questions about the way they're
collecting the data or what they're
considering
as a dev so there are a lot of
discussion but
i think this is out for us at the end of
the day to
decide if this data
is reliable or not well what we are
trying to do is to only perform reliable
resource and so for example john hopkins
we consider the most reliable or
governmental
at the end of the day probably even john
hopkins when they're pulling from some
countries they it's very hard to verify
on the country based
how reliable is the data yeah that we've
under
that that we've seen a lot of in the
news
uh we have a conversation going on in a
thread i'm not sure there's so much a
question for you as it is a
a um a
comment um alan is talking about i
believe it's probably alan federer
uh asking about he started to look at
historical data it's all contained in
old git commits each day they overwrite
the data
is there any easy way to query through
old commits
um so alan i assume you could hear me
are you referencing the old commits for
the project romney's working on
for the new york times data and the
coveter cover 19 project are you
referencing something else
i'll give alan he's referencing old
commits from the nyc health data
that looks like there's a nice thread
going on there so rather than me trying
to read the whole thread
around me one of the things that ln also
in this project is how to query a github
api
so i think there is a way that you can
actually go and get all these local
commits and then based on the data there
you can
get the number of the like the code of
the commit and
pull uh get do do a
git pull based on the end of the
commit the code and there is a few there
is a few are packages for working at the
uh github api at least one for working
the github api
and there is i do believe the
vignette httr package talks about how to
use the api using curl if you don't want
to use the github package itself
so there's lots of opportunities to go
do exactly what romney's talking about
another question we had was is there
data on the number of tests being done
on a county level
uh i don't think we have it on our data
set
i can quickly check it
but i know it's available somewhere i
think that
um let me see
so i can check the
now it's only for this one it's only the
total cases and death and i
i think when what uh one of the things
that uh
i learned while i was trying to pull
data for the u.s is that
um each state report different
data or different parameters that they
are providing
not all the it's not any uniform
and i think that i saw i forgot what is
the name of the
website but there is a website that
actually give rank
for the data quality oh that sounds
awesome yeah so they are actually i
think it's the
conveyed art it's not good without the
can find the website it's called
kovid19 tracker
uh the way they have this slack channel
they actually
can find the website there
i can't share it later but they have
actually they are doing a good job on
tracking data in the u.s this is
probably one of the best resource
to get data from the us and
and the package the first package that
the amanda
created was to pull data from this api
the
complete 19 us by amanda
is just doing pulling this data from
there so we can actually
i'm not sure if it's here
maybe it's you know in a given
repository but it's it's
it's followed the same idea that you can
you can uh
pull data by state from there
so that's in the uh the cover 19r thing
so
everything says nice uniform place for
everything that's pretty awesome
uh and i do believe amanda is attending
the meetup right now i saw her name in
the uh
in the zoom attendees and she is on the
slack and she's a regular member of the
meetup and conference
so she's a local resource as part of
this team so everyone
say hi and thank amanda when you have a
chance
i mean thank romney too but he's not
from new york no he
she has a major part of this project
i think what's nice in this project that
each one
coming from a different background uh
she has more she has experience in data
engineers she created all this
infrastructure of the complete our
package uh
that will it she created like a api
style package uh
so really appreciate their work on this
so everyone next time you see her in
person new york we ever see her thank
her
this is um so israel is asking a
question
and he admits it's long-winded i'm
actually trying to see what the question
says but he's asking about data on
comorbidity at the subject level for the
u.s
are there good sources for that
i'm not sure
i'm not familiar i mean i
i know i saw
i think reuters or one of those
big media agencies provides
provide some visualization about it
about mobility in the u.s
but i it's good
i'm sorry i'm not sure like i'm trying
to find this
source of data and it didn't really
provide like a
api or something that can be used
i believe it wasn't asked about mobility
but co-morbidity
oh like i think he wants data at the
subject level basically he's saying
is there anything non-aggregated i don't
think
i and there's probably like a legal
issue to provide this data
that's my guess i would i never saw
such beside i think singapore
they when i started to look for that at
singapore it's actually
on the individual because at the
beginning they have like 160 people
but i think once it's moved to massive
amount of people it's very hard to track
this information and therefore there is
a privacy issue to get this data
yeah probably a lot of hipaa issues uh
to get this data
uh yeah so
uh another question here um which is a
question
i guess i can answer is is there um ilia
is asking is there
an evil is there availability for giving
a talk on asset management using xts
uh so i'm not sure about asset managed
directly but jeff ryan did give a talk
last year
at the meetup so you go to nyhakgar.org
and search for jeff ryan he gave an xds
talk and if someone wants to give an
asset management talk message me that's
the way this works you come up with an
idea you have to do it
um a question from kevin
is do you have population count by
county or state
um i don't have
i mean i don't ever directly on this
package but i know it's available
on the us census bureau
that you can actually uh
someone actually ping me about it i
can't find it but there is
somewhere that they have a ship file
that has this information about the
population
the amount of people or some more
economical data
by county so this data i believe
it's available and actually it will be
nice analysis to
merge those defensive there are some
insights about it
and there are at least two r packages
for
getting census data i believe one's
called census api
and one called tidy census and i believe
there's even a third package which i
the name is escaping me so yeah you have
multiple chances to get census data
which
would handle that um
we have a question this is actually not
a question it's a point of reference
from pete talking about the
imehe the uw forecasting group they
provide
estimated infections at the state level
not sure at the county level and they
probably do for other countries and
infections is probably a good basis to
use when evaluating death rates
that wasn't so much a question but i
think more of a comment unless you have
a opinion on that romney
i so i thought about the
about so the reason that i started to
pull this data i was interested because
i'm coming from time series background
and uh i was interested
to see if maybe i can forecast some
trend or something it is but like
literally the day after i pulled the
data i realized that
i don't have enough domain knowledge
because
my opinion that and i think that also
norm
ross mentioned it on his talk that the
way that
pandemic work is different from
it's not like a human behavior that is
easy to forecast
there are other parameters that unless
you have them
it's very model the density of the
population and
when you put the shelter in place and
other places
other factors i see it like
it's like forecast the stock market you
don't have enough information to do it
so
don't don't just don't do it yeah that's
actually supposed to uh forecast the
volatility come on
let's go
if they were walking so probably some
people were very
rich now yes oh some are
um then we have a someone actually
commenting that would the world bank be
a great source of getting national
populations
um you know the world bank and believe
it or not actually the cia factbook
has a lot of that type of information um
and
probably the world bank has to have that
somewhere too
we have a question from john saying is
there funding for this and does it need
funding
for i guess the coven 19 project so
we don't have funding we just
uh three people that just decided to
contribute to the open source
one of the things that we talked about
that if we get funding maybe we can
put it in some a place like aws
and create like api that will be easy to
get the data
one of the things that i did in my
package when i started i created also
for each packet the csv file that it
will
also enable other users that are not
our user to get access to the data but i
think it doesn't matter if you're using
or not even if you i know anything
make the data accessible and make
awareness for this data i think it's
important
it's a good reason absolutely
so then we have a question let me
pull it up oh it's actually not a
question it's a comment from amanda
saying the the cova tracking api the
code to wrap it
is under um ae dublin uh slash covet 19
u.s
uh but she said maybe she's transferred
ownership to covet 19r um
just a comment but i'll relay it to you
since you can't read things too quickly
so
uh um i think that the idea is that
people will come and contribute they can
they can
put it in their repo
and we just need to have the structure
that allow us to
once we have the structure we can add it
to the copied all
packet and i think actually she's right
because she
i think it should be somewhere here
here yeah so you don't it doesn't need
to live in
in the copy the are copying our repo
a project it could be on on
[Music]
on your own repository but as long as
it's running the same format
we can pull the data and have it
available on the uh
with our data package
great so you don't need to transfer
ownership i mean that makes it easier no
yeah um yuri was responding to william
saying yeah the world bank has excellent
info
and william actually has another
question is there any information about
when there are state and national
lockdown dates like
when did each state and country decide
to lock down the population
um i'm sure there is somewhere
that's uh i'm not
familiar with like one place that you
can get for all the stats
i i'm i think that the copy the tracker
might have some more information it's a
good resource for the u.s
it's a project that is by far much
massive than what we are doing we have
three people there there are like
hundreds of people working on it and
they are doing a great job to collect
data
so they might have this um
someone probably should have it also
another
interesting data to like one descriptive
and rcc like the relationship between
uh the shuttle in place and
the infection rate or something like
this now we're gonna and that's only
that's not a continuing well it's not
supposed to be a continuing data set
like the lockdown is one
point in time we might have a second
round of lockdowns later on
but it's not something they need to
update so if someone could just find
that it could be a csv that never gets
touched again
until we get the you know a rebound back
in the fall
all right um yuri also responded to
william that imf has a lot of good uh
a lot of good data it's not just about
um
the population but about cover 19 in
general imf has a lot of information
i'm not sure that there's been talk
about including that in your project
so uh until now we just we're focusing
on
get so to get the structure uh we have
like the example that's available there
which is the
friends that amanda cognite in france
which i mean the
build the new york times state and
county
there is a canada that morgan is the
first one to contribute
to this project
and coming the swiss and italy
but we will mainly focus on creating the
structure which took us a lot of time
and it's still something that we are
testing that well to us the data
and have the ability to pull it really
fast
and update i think this is the major
uh effort that we had in the recent
few weeks and we hope that
setting these tools will enable other
people just create packages with data
without
having to go through all these processes
that's that's a very good point you want
to make it as quick and seamless
yeah and i think like we also when we
started to talk with the next steps
probably would be to create package that
support
data visualization there are a lot of
visualization that
now seems like a are very unique to the
kobe 19
that once the data has the same
structure
uh it is very easy to create one
function that you
uh take the data no matter if it's a
france
us county or anything as long as there
are the parameters are the
same that you can point to them and get
some visualization
so i think this is one of the next steps
shiny we talked about creating a shiny
app
uh stuff like this but this is kind of
like when
the data uh part will finish will be at
least
the stable state so i'm gonna ask
i have to ask a question do you have a
timeline for when you think you're gonna
do it
uh unfortunately no because it's more
like a
weekend project yep uh
at the beginning uh when we were in
normal routine
uh i had more time on the afternoons
when i finished the walk
after the shadowing play style to take
place it's
more challenging to walk during the day
and working now it's more like
intervals between kids and uh
and free time and so now it's
literally strictly like something that
i'm focusing on weekends
um but that's why we hope that others
will
join us and contribute to their fault
yes and i want to echo that again uh
everyone who hears the ability the time
the interest do
contribute to this everyone knows this
meetup's all about open source
and the more contributions open source
the better particularly
something as important as this right now
so i like to encourage
all the members to contribute as much as
they can whenever
they can of in their abilities
uh so one more is there's a comment from
rajon
talking about there are 538 visualized
population lockdown dates so that means
they got the data somewhere
so that there are data is available but
may they they could have actually just
gone
compiled by hand because they could have
put had an intern go and collect 200
pieces of information
could have done that in a day that's my
guess what they did but the data if not
you could copy it from 538
if you get it from there somehow all
right
so i think that is all the questions we
had
uh so just want to give a big virtual
round of applause you won't be able to
hear us but at least i'll clap into my
microphone
for romney for the great talk thank you
very much for being here
thank you for coming all the way from
the west coast to speak at our new york
meetup
my pleasure and thank you for having me
here as we are very happy i was very
happy when you agreed to talk um
i was very excited about that and again
if
anyone ever have questions and want to
contribute we
please feel free to contact me
i'm in the slack channel
or you can email me or any other methods
with you or something like this but uh
we encourage people to come and join us
yeah and i think that's a very key
takeaway here more than ever we always
encourage them and
highly encourage everyone to go contact
get involved contact them
i know both amanda and rami are in the
coven 19 channel on slack
and like you said there's other ways to
get in touch with them
so as we are closing up here just want
to remind everyone
june will be announced shortly as soon
as we get a date lockdown
be sure to check out eram in italy be
sure to check out nyr in new york in
august
and uh stay stay up to date on slack in
the mailing list for other events
we have a lot coming a lot of cool
things we're gonna do as much as we can
during the lockdown
and one day we'll see each other again
in person but until then we're going to
keep
getting distant speakers to speak
otherwise we wouldn't have the
opportunity to join our group
so um a very big thank you to romney
once again for speaking hope everyone
has a great night
enjoy your pizza wherever you may be
enjoy the rest of your evening or day or
midnight wherever you are everyone have
a great one and we'll see you next month
bye and also wanted to mention the the
pizza tours
oh yes oh my goodness so sorry i forgot
the uh amada thank you very much
yes before everyone leaves um everyone
knows how we are obsessed with pizza in
this
meetup and we have our our pizza poll
well
since we can't get much pizza lately
scott's pizza tour so people know i'm a
big fan of
sponsoring this month's meetup and i
forgot to mention it
if you want to take a virtual pizza tour
you get 25
off by using code nerds love pizza
so that's a great user code it's scott's
pizza tours if anyone doesn't know that
uh people someone know me i used to be
one of the tour guides there
um so when i wrote my thesis about pizza
people give it to scott
uh so we're very excited that he was
sponsoring our meetup this month
and because we love his tour and the
virtual one's actually pretty cool you
don't get to eat any pizza
you get to learn a lot about pizza which
is the whole point anyway uh so
even though you're not getting your dose
of pizza in the meetup go to scott's
pizza tours they're really cool
i personally vouch for them being a
former attendee and a former tour guide
i really love them
with that thank you mata for reminding
me of that that's very nice oh john
loves
the casa santa claus is a great place
john yes it is i hope everyone else tell
me where you've been getting pizza
lately i need to hear this
i i'm having withdrawal from all the
good pizza places and i know ram you
probably don't have any good pizza on
the west coast that's just the way it is
and don't tell me delfino i don't i
don't want to hear it it's fine for the
west coast
but all right yeah if you have a place i
want to hear it
ah all right well your time i was never
gonna oven's never gonna be hot enough i
appreciate making it home i do try
occasionally too all right so thank you
very much
yeah yeah do you i want to see a photo
of your pizza now
i will send great thank you thank you
and everyone else
send photos to your pizza to the slack
channel why not that's part of our
meetup
and thank you ecohealth alliance for
providing the zoom link
so thank you amada for making sure i
remember to thank everyone who's
sponsoring us
uh yeah so uh those i mentioned his name
so many times but noam has been a
critical here in helping us out uh the
zoom link is provided by equal health
alliance like they did last month
uh it's a big help to us managing to get
so many people on a slack channel and
such good quality
sorry in the zoom conference such good
quality
so thank you very much equal health
alliance in general and gnome in
particular for making that happen thank
you very much and thank you mata for
reminding me of all these things i
supposed to have said
thank you for organizing the meetups
thank you
and with that i will send everyone home
to go get dessert i have some border
ices waiting for me
i'm going to go dig into that and hope
everyone has a wonderful time and be in
touch on slack
being in touch contact us just uh let us
know what's going on
uh thank you everyone for being here
have a great night or day or evening
depending where you are and thank you
romney again thanks romney
thank you so much thank you